brain surgery holiday the second leading
scorer on this team last season but
basketball taken a backseat as it should
another turnover that buddy hield was
able to capitalize on as he intercepts
another pass and then finishes on the
other end good deflection buddy hield
pre-entered it buddy on the run against
Burton's will take it the distance 20
dad the flippers biggest lead early was
eight Austin Rivers buddy looking for
his first he's got it and he hadn't
settled by John wall's
and the percentage buster is give it up
buddy hield he'll get there rush as well
on a national championship for Rick
Pitino with rust Incubus of the
backboard Russ Smith buddy and should be
going any Whoopie
Brandon Rush hooked on his way up
reverse by Booker on the other end
rolled up by a point healed with his
second shot
Atlantic's at home breathe from the
corner go by Chris
there's a lot of there's healed for the
hometown crowd
51 Tony Allen's knocked away by
cauley-stein to the floor II thought
what an effort
Collison
well basketball by the case we
cauley-stein with a steel to the floor
gets it ahead to Collison and there it
is buddy with the finish but how about
that play by Paulie Stein that's
absolutely a great play you talk about
Willie hustle Stein right there I mean
these doll the wall goes on the floor
for it knocks it loose with the left
hand I mean that that is a highlight for
the day right there
here's buddy hield
and that makes it a two-point game and
it's taken by Lawson numbers dangerous
pass
and putting they'll mix it board up and
Buddy hield nicely done in one motion
for a really great look again because if
Tyler Ulis to small lunch time Lawson
here to scout lobby's here actually the
Buddy hield I beg your pardon
yeah here once he turned back the owner
and he saw buddy with Tyler Ulis in
front of him and Tyler not tall enough
just probably something and there is
another long ball for Buddy hield he
picks up right where he left off last
night oh you want about the talent they
have here and it's stacked now but if
they're going to do it it's going to be
Chris Paul that takes a minute sure he's
the guy he's the guy
he's got 14 winning in those programs
healed going strong to the rack buddy
hield aspiring to be a closer going
strong to the front of the rim he's got
cauley-stein and healed ahead of him
buddy to cauley-stein how beautiful is
that excellent play by Buddy hield just
a little drop back pass very unselfish
play by the Kings cauley-stein buddy
looking for three in a row
starting to get into a rhythm
that's good offense my buddy hield Wow
nice job buddy buddy buddy here and
watch buddy's defense as you said
turning to offense yes being very
aggressive running bender on that
situation and going coast-to-coast
making sure if they don't stop the ball
take it right to the rouse technology
lift up TV announcers receive the Aaron
Fox Liston's spectacular work on the
defensive end and the speed gets as a
buddy running late by the pool and now
they will just use some pot here's buddy
hield oh wow what a move by buddy he'll
just pull up and just take that shot
yeah I mean that's he's got space paper
forget the three-ball
they're setting up for buddy Henrietta's
now with quick Madonna Buddy hield
to tie the game
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's poke Donovan black shot Costa two
seconds got a hurry buddy beats the pot
stores
fadeaway jumper is goodbye buddy hield
tough shot he's got five points off my
buddy here well that's a carry they
didn't call it buddy hield hits I cared
about three times right - set up the
half hooked instead goes to cauley-stein
a lot of congestion in there now a bad
pass picked off Kings with this big
turnover and Buddy hield box it out of
Alec on scout
in a hurry
nicely done I mean good stuff right here
Malachi drops it off
no panic and scowl Scalf mine scalp now
free to shoot but he sees it he's in
front of his bench he knows he has to
fire and he beats the clock but he
heeled nice pass to Sampson from Fox and
out these circles back out buddy
beats the shot clock good scores buddy
Hill with a beautiful shot two-point
game six point nine Warriors have hit a
little pass where they drop some games
healed out of the timeout drills the
triple again in doing is just a little
slow that time on buddy Hill coming up
heard his curling back out off of the
post it
just a really quick release
[Applause]
with the hoop 31:22 buddy hield buddy it
because buddy Heil double town boy what
a sequence that was to end the first
quarter the Ellington basket beats the
horn
3124 at the end of 12 minutes this
quarter for the Warriors the Kings
meanwhile if this goes that will be
their 7 yes hey dusk Oh buddy here damn
sweet draymond Green and with 12 minutes
gone by here in Oakland it's 36 29 now
the shot clock to five
they got healed to have dish that's a
big time shot right there
yeah well he's defended here
but just get some little separation by a
stepping back there and that's all he
needs
that's very marketable and they do six
seconds
Bogdanovich buddy here buddy
here we saw it at the end of the first
quarter and he does the same thing at
the end of the third quarter
seventy five
[Music]
buddy Hills got a hurry buddy hield a
three-pointer doing what double check
and look at the clock in two three well
I hate this rule and I know I get it
I hate stopping the rhythm of a game for
this type of a replay it's often and
clearly a free they live to be able to
see that pretty quick
[Applause]
13 seconds left comes away watch all the
depo he is right there takes a little
just a little step away and without
stepping out of bounds but he's got that
yeah that's an amazing play little step
back thank you very much good pass at
the buzzer D Aaron Fox with his fifth
assist to Buddy hield he beats the clock
played and there's no doubt about it
buddy Hill takes us to the break 5749
warriors on NBC Sports but he's the man
off the bench with eight working on
Tucker how about the use and ahhs from
the crowd here in Sacramento Buddy Hill
that's learned how to create his shot
[Applause]
buddy hield fouled and put it in the
book and set them Tuttle eye that points
off the leg of the defenders it is not
an intentional kick oh good
you just gotta love the way he competes
force
look at him hustle and gets his hand on
the basketball well done don't give up
on to play says buddy teen rebounds for
Hassan Whiteside and five rejections
back Lee is in oh what a pass to Buddy
Hill Wow
and in mr. Bagley with a nice little
backdoor cut by Buddy hield delivers out
the bucket three in down the hall this
has been an issue buddy hield
how do you like that play that was a
thing of beauty
[Applause]
off balance doesn't matter that's buddy
hield so buddy Hill makes a really tough
shot every single time you got a create
your own energy in this good buddy hield
and a chance for a four-point play for
buddy is the Kings retake the lead the
elites in knows that he's got time
box buddy oh that's incredible what a
play
great designed by the Aaron Fox
[Music]
and buddy is gonna get a chance at a
three-point play
tough shot but we are talking about
funny spread the love buddy love that's
big 74-66 buddy buddy Oh buddy deal with
one second left Gordon s game in eight
minutes which is very unusual won't last
the long oh boy
[Applause]
55:48 but he heals deep three but what's
what's faculty gonna do if he catches
that no-good long rebound the elite
Senapati healed buddy clapping the
letter n trimming at home
that chance but one more but you can say
I got a body this evening babe and hang
on Hurricanes box six seconds buddy Hill
buddy step-back baseline buddy filled
with six tenths of a second lap before a
minutes gone by
it's the Kings on top 61 the 58 on
empathy touched everything for winning
the best
6556 nice pass buddy hill right now
doing at all a single will do but the
Kings are looking for a home run look at
this pass that thing is on a rope right
there buddy hield reach up knock down
and one may be the success for the king
sent home has just pulled out by 19
every game Sacramento by a point with
just over two minutes left buddy hield
finds tiles 28:25 easy shots and what
does that do it softens up a tough
defense
they'll be fair bit of the careless pass
right there by the Aaron because they
are so good on the defensive end give up
he'll score three
102 98 with in-state buddy hield boy I'm
telling you is he fun to watch dog
incredible you've been the one guy for
the magic tonight they can knock it down
from outside Oh
what about Globetrotters are coming in a
town stuns the crowd here in Detroit or
uno dos tres well I'll pay this 7258
Oh what about bye party to set up
Shumpert
goes back to what we're talking about
with buddy much the set up by Buddy
hield and it's am on Shumpert by the way
that foul on buddy is his fourth killed
knows he's got time you looked at the
clock before he picked up the ball
that's just tremendous effort by Buddy
hield
buddy buckets and his best-known a deep
ball cutting to the basket and Fox finds
the Oklahoma sooner lawrence likes this
matchup iike that looks at a double-team
the budding shot clock at four
but he sees it knows he has to create
tough shot what we are talking about
plenty buckets box
a lot of times anger and Fox mislead him
track that basketball up above dat in
ICU mr. lucky he does a little bit of
everything he continues to drill or the
players now he picks up off switch
jumper
right here here we look at in the sit-up
ask me that wrong but he said I got this
Sacramento into the paynus box no good
buddy hield oh if you don't like that
you know like NBA basketball he look
right here he comes in this is buddy
Bunny's right there just go up above and
throw it down why don't you if you don't
block him out put the bunnies on the
button we got you to guard right there
coming in the wins at this accident 91
90 does babies now get the block shot
look at who's there again buddy hield
that's why I just said that that'll help
him find his rip what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content